- Hey everyone, so today in the office
I thought why not shake things up
with an interesting game
of would you rather.
I'm gonna be asking some coworkers
some rather unusual would
you rather questions.
So, let's see what they have to say.
(peppy music)
Would you rather
have your girlfriend switch
bodies with your dad for a year
or would you rather switch
genders for two years?
- I'd rather switch genders for two years.
- Yeah?
- Yeah, I don't need my
girlfriend in my dad's body.
- You'll just be a beautiful woman?
- Yes, thank you for your confidence.
- Would you rather be
pregnant for two years
or have your period for two years?
- I would rather be
pregnant for two years.
Because I could get away with
eating whatever I wanted.
Who wants their period
for two years, my god.
- I dunno, maybe Tampax will
sponsor you or something.
- Think of all the sex you couldn't have.
- Would you rather watch
your parents have sex
every day for the rest of your life
or join them once?
(laughs)
- I would get used to it.
There are so many
questions that go into it.
How long are they going to take?
What would I have to do?
I really value my time,
and so even though it would be horrible
I would probably just join them once
so that way I would never
have to do it again.
- You're a brave soul.
Would you rather fart
every time you told a lie,
and very loudly, or sneeze
in your crush's face
every time they entered a room?
- These are awful.
I like people,
so I wouldn't want to
sneeze in my crush's face
all the time.
It would just encourage
me, I guess, not to lie.
So, I think I'd go with that one.
- Would you rather have your
ex's name tattooed on your body
or refer to your partner
only by pet names,
to them, to everyone forever?
- The tattoo thing is like,
can you get it covered up
into like a sick dolphin
or something, or no?
- No.
- Then I'm gonna call the person I love
by the pet names.
I had a boyfriend who I used to call poop.
- That's really romantic.
- I think it's cute!
- I think, yeah.
- We don't care what you think.
- So those were their answers.
Which one of these things
would you rather do?
Leave a comment below with your answers
and I'll see you real soon.
- [Black Haired Man] Would
you rather have teeth
for pubic hair or pubic hair for teeth?
- Why did you think of this?